this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the dave ramsey show the ramsay show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice christy
wright ramsey personality
and number one best-selling author of
the book business boutique
is my co-host today as we take your
questions about life and about money
it is a free call at triple eight eight
two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five you jump in
and we will talk rachel is going to
start off this hour
she's in washington d.c hi rachel how
are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so my question is i have a rental home
it used to be
my uh home and then i i moved out when
my husband passed away about
uh almost five years ago and so it's
been
it's been about three years i've been
renting it so now
i'm at a point where i'm trying to
decide do i get rid of it
or do i do i still keep it i owe about
uh 338 on it it was about 525.
[Music]
and where are you living i i bought
another home you bought another
home okay all right i did yeah and how's
your career going
well right now i um in october of 2019
or so
um i started a business uh at
tax and accounting for small businesses
a type of business not not doing too too
well right now
kind of maybe deciding to jump back into
the workforce um
okay so that little bit of pinch
uh on the income side makes you look at
this rental
yes yeah so he's gonna change why
because after all the smoke clears with
the occasional vacancy and the
occasional repair
you're not making a ton on this thing
not really i mean it's covering the uh
the mortgage and
just a little bit over that and that's
about it yeah there's not not much
wiggle room in this deal
so um it just sounds like there's not a
lot of reasons to keep it
yeah i mean i was kind of holding on to
it for thinking about but you know
the home that we shared with my my
husband but yeah at this point i'm at a
crossroads a little bit
well i understand and you know part of
that
uh holding on to it went away when you
rented it right
yeah i mean that that's like you know
you're moving it from
the home where we did life to now a
business transaction
but that gave you a little further time
to put some distance between you and his
passing
a little bit more healing right right
yeah
yeah yeah i mean emotionally letting go
of it today is different than it would
have been four years ago
yeah at the time i wasn't ready yeah i
definitely wasn't ready yeah
so chrissy i wonder how her business
would be affected if she didn't have
this strain
yeah i'm just thinking about just the
progression even as as you're describing
this rachel from like you're saying five
years ago and then now because even if
you do sell it now
it doesn't mean it's gonna be easy it's
still you're still gonna have that
emotional pull it'll be easier than it
was five years ago but it's still
not gonna be easy but i just wonder what
could be freed up
if you did let it go what could be freed
up in your emotions
in the headache of having to deal with
it i mean having a rental is not just
free money coming in like that that's
work on your part it's maintenance it's
the
the dealing with the day-to-day of it
and so um i i think that while it might
be difficult to walk through that
to sell it what would be on the other
side would be worth it
i mean you have a couple hundred
thousand dollars in your pocket i'm just
wondering if your business might
if you took a little strain off of you
and just leaned into that business if
you can make that business turn the
corner
rather than head back into the workforce
uh sometimes
stress and the the weight of several
things on you keep you from focusing on
the business and
i think there might be a release there
so i'm definitely selling it
um i have no reasons on my list over
talking to you to keep it
uh you're gonna be free uh i mean the
there'll be some sadness but but it
doesn't make you any money
uh it's it's really at the end of the
day from a financial standpoint it's
really not a blessing at this point
and the uh having the actual money in
the bank out of that equity would be
and i'll give you some options and stay
on the line rachel because i would love
to send you
my book business boutique there's i
cover a lot of different aspects of
business in this book it's your plan to
win but it also
might help you identify what's not
working is it your pricing is it your
customers is it your marketing what
hasn't been working in your small
business that you could like dave said
improve fix iterate to be able to make
that thing work
in this new season so stay on the line
and kelly can send that to you
absolutely yeah all right noah's with us
in uh fort worth texas hi noah how are
you
good how are you dude better than i
deserve how can we help
great so i am having a hard time
trying to decide between saving up for a
down payment on a house
or investing i really want to start
investing more
into my retirement income okay
you can do that so uh great so i
am 23 years old i just finished baby
step three
um you know i really
i want to start investing more into my
retirement just because i see
the potential outcome of that and i
really don't have housekeeper right now
but
i also want to have enough for a down
payment and
hopefully i guess if i ever wanted to go
well what are you making
i make 70 dollars good for you at 23.
what are you doing
uh business intelligence very good yeah
and that's going to go nowhere but up
from there
where are you living now right i'm
living at home right now
but i got an apartment i'm moving into
you next month okay that's a good plan
i think that's a really good first step
and if you're putting 15 of your income
away
and baby step four into retirement can
you not save towards the house above
that
no yeah i can and that was my original
plan but i didn't know if i should be
sitting because that's like almost
an extra six thousand dollars a year i
could be saving for a house but
you know well i mean and you know three
years from now you'd have 18 000 you'd
be 26 years old that's not the end of
the world
or at any point you want to dial back
baby step four and we'll do what we call
baby step three b which is a reduced or
temporarily put on hold baby step four
while you save
aggressively for a down payment more
aggressively uh that'll be fine
but um you're making good money and
here's the thing uh three years from
today you're not gonna be making 70 000
in business intelligence that's exactly
what i was going to say i was like
you're going to be making more so you're
already going to make
that goal faster yeah i i think you can
put 15 away and still have a house in
two to three years
and i think that's a fine plan there's
nothing wrong with that at all
awesome thank you i really appreciate
the help hey thanks for the call we
appreciate you joining us
open phones at 825-5225 so christy when
you're running a business or your own
budget
uh projections are good uh looking out
in the future and projecting your
numbers
are are good uh the first thing we tend
to do is we tend to just take what we
know today
and extend that yeah linearly assuming
it's gonna be the exact same you know
like in his case he's going to make 70
000 for the next three years and you and
i are looking at each other going
23 is making 70 already right business
intelligence is a hot topic
a lot of stuff happening with data right
now it's one of the hottest you know
career fields you could possibly get
into in the tech world right and
uh and if he's good at it and leans in
which he apparently is because he's
already landing stuff
then he you know it's very possible
folks that he doubles his income in
three years
right right and so you don't take your
business income or your personal income
and necessarily project it on a line
like i'm making whatever i'm making now
i'm always going to make that it's
very seldom you do that now some jobs
you're in you get cost living raising
that's it but other positions you're in
wow you can really be on a curve the
same thing's true with your business
with a product line
or anything else that's right this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
well this week is national financial
literacy month not this week this month
is
and we always celebrate that by
celebrating teachers
because christie you and i both know
that teachers make the world go around
the good ones
yes the ones that don't mail it in yes
we can all look back in our past and go
that teacher influenced me in that area
that teacher
i mean i can name five or six off the
top of my head that had a big impact uh
some of the others i don't even remember
their names yep that's right but uh
but they're all that coaches teachers
these kinds of people come across your
life they
they're life changers yeah the good ones
and so we want to honor the teachers we
think you're awesome in the past year
you've pivoted you've prepared for all
scenarios
you try to say stay safe and still love
your kids and teach your kids
and make an impact on your kids on the
students and that's why we're
celebrating educators with our teacher
appreciation giveaway
it's sponsored by mint mobile the
affordable premium
wireless provider because of the hard
work and dedication of teachers our
foundations in personal finance
curriculum has now been taught in more
than 48
of the high schools in america and
impacted the lives of over 5
million students uh to say thanks for
inviting teachers to enter our teacher
appreciation giveaway
we're giving away amazing prizes like
for instance the grand prize
five thousand dollars cash there's no
purchase necessary you just gotta sign
up to uh
be registered then no need to sign up
more than once because that puts you in
the hat put your name in the hat and
we're gonna do a drawing among you
amazing teachers you go to
ramseysolutions.com
slash teacher to enter the giveaway ends
april the 30th speaking of amazing
teachers
we have emmy burns from centerberg ohio
zunderberg high school
who is a teacher of our high school
curriculum the foundations in
personal finance hey amy how are you i
am fantastic
thank you and yourself well just the
same i'm honored to speak with you
and i'm honored to be with you so you've
been teaching
uh for how many years overall this is my
eighth year teaching i'm a second career
teacher
wow good for you thank you and so and
you've been teaching the finance
curriculum the personal finance
personal foundations and personal
finance curriculum i can't say it
uh for how long for about five years now
oh so most of the time you've been
teaching then
absolutely yeah very cool so what's the
kids reaction to this
they are so excited and mostly because
they've
most of our students recognize you in
your face
from their their parents uh going
through financial peace university
oh okay well that can be good and that
can be bad
depending depending
[Music]
tell me about the cli tell me about the
class when the students are asking
questions
what is the what's the initial response
or what's the
the quest the type of questions that
they have when they first are getting it
you know
introduced to this curriculum you know
it just runs the gamut they're just
they're all over the board it depends on
what year it is what you know
what time of the semester it is but
mostly
those students are wanting to know like
what's one thing that they can cut out
of their budget that wouldn't make a
huge change in their daily life
another one would be um you know i still
have some
moments in their life that they can be
very impulsive
and what are some tips that they can get
out of you know
get out of that habit yeah yeah that's
that's powerful
i'm curious amy so i spoke to teenagers
when i first started at this company
and one of the things i struggled with
and talking to teenagers was that
some of them many of them didn't really
have an interest because money seemed
like this far off topic
you know it seemed like that thing i'll
have to deal with later and they had the
bank of mom and dad a 24-hour atm so
they didn't really have an incentive to
live on budget
how do you help them get motivated
excited
you know about learning this right now
before they make all those mistakes
well i have to say that i am very
privileged to
to work in a school district where um
we don't see that a lot oh wow we have
very self-sufficient
students here um with families that
encourage them to
earn their way and so i i
get a very different um atmosphere here
but as far as that goes um
my freshmen don't usually get the whole
financial
personal finance idea because they
haven't had
jobs yet they're still coming out of
middle school but once the kids get into
to be sophomores and juniors and
especially seniors
they're starting to get jobs they're
starting to look at getting a car
etc etc so um those
things are the kids that are
sophomores juniors and seniors they have
a better grasp that makes sense of
of what personal finance is and the
importance of they're working yeah
yeah exactly so in the five years you've
been teaching this what are your class
sizes and
and how many people have gone through it
well i'd like you to remember that we
have
less than 350 students in our school oh
in the whole school
in the whole school we're very small
we're rural school here in ohio
and i have had anywhere from about 15
to a full class of 25. wow
that's a lot and within the next two
years i hear a rumor coming down the
pike that
ohio will start requiring
personal financial management as a
graduation requirement
wow i hope so that's awesome i hope so
too our guys in the uh our education
department are involved in the lobbying
in a bunch of states
a lot of states have made it mandatory
and we get in there and talk to the
legislatures as often as we can to let
them know that yeah this is what the
kids need
and because all of us that are adults
you know we look back and we go
why didn't they teach us this in school
you know we say
also in the same routine and yet there's
teachers like amy and 48
of the high schools that are doing this
so
very cool thank you so much you're
obviously a rock star we appreciate you
teaching this and well thank you
we appreciate you taking a second to
talk to us about it we're so so proud to
be
associated with you and i'm proud to
have you out there so thank you thank
you thank you for being one of those
superstar teachers that doesn't
mail it in that that really does change
lives
so you know when you're teaching
something and you and i
have the same experience as teachers
we're teachers
uh in a different vein in a sense but
when we get somebody back
five years later that's exactly right
and they say man i went to that seminar
and it changed my life
that's right the information yep changed
my life sometimes i say you changed my
life which is not
true i didn't or you didn't but what we
were teaching them when they applied it
did right and that's what amy's doing
and so you i can't imagine being a high
school teacher that has a
25 year old comeback right what six
seven eight years later and said
you know when you taught that you set me
up to win with my new spouse and my new
kid and yeah
wow it's really interesting too because
i feel like especially in high school
you could apply this to any time in life
but especially high school
a lot of times those students that come
in as freshmen and they leave as seniors
they're older and they're taller but
they're not acting all that different
and the teacher it would be easy to feel
like oh i didn't make a difference in
their life because i didn't see this
huge transformation in these four years
but the seeds that are planted it's
amazing how that
continues to grow and they come back at
25 and you hear these success stories
and i can think of gosh
all the people that poured into me in
high school from teachers to coaches my
young life leader
seeds they planted that now
are coming to fruition you're seeing the
fruit of that but of course when i left
as a senior they probably didn't feel
like oh my gosh you know i see a huge
change in
in christy brown you know at the time
and so i just i i hope that's an
encouragement to teachers coaches those
people that are
teaching these classes even if you don't
see a huge transformation
in your class or in those four years the
seeds you're planting
are going to produce fruit later and it
matters
you were a young life leader and you
experienced the exact same thing from
the leader perspective
rachel cruz who was young life leader
daniel ramsey my son was a young life
leader and so
again work that's working ministry with
teens but um
but i mean you can get some kid who's
just stuck on stupid
i mean they're just stuck on stupid and
yet they're still hearing you
yeah and all of a sudden it dislodges
the stupid dislodges at some point and
they turn a corner
and you're you may not be around when
that happens right but
you still planted the seeds in there
that caused it to happen that's right
just uh just actually this week i was
doing a
facebook and instagram live walking
through my devotional and i held up my
bible i don't think i've ever shown it
on you know on camera and i said this is
the bible that a friend gave me in high
school and it was a friend that saw
something in me
that i didn't see in myself and i don't
even know was present at the time but he
saw something in me and i still treasure
that bible to this day just thinking of
how far that bible has brought me you
didn't see it when i was a sophomore or
even a senior
but you begin to see it over time and
sometimes we get those success stories
and sometimes we don't
but it's just a good reminder that uh
that those seeds
continue to grow yeah yeah oh by the way
the devotional
is called living true 40 days to get
back to you
and you're going through it again on
instagram right now right yeah leading
people through it in these 40 days
after easter when jesus would have
appeared to people on the earth it's
been a fun journey so far
get your copy at christywright.com
devotional or at ramseysolutions.com
and if they want to follow you it's at
christy wright at christina
christiebright on instagram
on instagram be sure you jump in there
if you want to join her on the
devotional process
this is the ramsey show
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money it's a free call a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
kendra is with us kendra's in san
antonio texas kendra it says on my
screen you are debt-free congratulations
thank you dave i'm very happy to be
making this phone call right now
that's awesome how much have you paid
off well i paid off 59
139 in about five years
good for you and your range of income
during that five years
i ranged from about 32 to 52.
wow what do you do for a living i'm an
environmental scientist
okay very good what kind of debt was the
59 000
well i had about 38 of school loans
and 21 of my car payment
okay all right so this was a struggle
for you
wasn't it it was um
yeah i just kept working hard and
putting as much as i could towards that
i got a good chunk of change from uh
some recent hail damage storm
so it made about 8k cosmetic damage
and i put it towards my car loan instead
so
and that cleaned it up the rest of the
way huh oh yeah
it definitely helped so it's got some
dents but i have it paid off and that's
that matters more to me so that's the
big next step yeah well done
well done thank you so what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
well just keep keep working hard and
putting as much as you can afford to
to those loans and stay motivated um i
had a great support system my
my brother and his wife are debt free
they paid off a
huge chunk they went through a financial
piece and
they they really helped me along the way
yeah
i mean you pay off ten thousand dollars
a year for five years
making 32 that's impressive
that's a marathon like that's a long
haul what was the hardest part
um i guess just
making sacrifices seeing that
pair of uh shoes that you really wanted
and
just said all control and just
really putting everything towards those
loans
yeah staying motivated that's good how
does it feel now that you're there
it feels incredible was it worth the
sacrifice
absolutely and i didn't think i'd
be here at my age making this phone call
right now how old are you i'm 28. 28
years old and you did this over five
years so you started when you were 23.
yes sir wow very impressive very
impressive thank you
well done definitely helped me a lot so
appreciate it
so your brother and sister-in-law were
cheerleaders because they had been
through financial peace university
who else was cheering you on uh
definitely my mom
and my dad so okay that's good news
she had good family support because
sometimes family goes you're crazy
you're always going to be in death
some people some people have family that
are losers right and uh you got you got
winners that are encouraging you and
lifting you up that's
very very cool well congratulations
kendra well done thank you thank you
we've got a copy of rachel cruz's latest
new york times
bestseller it's called know yourself
know your money kelly will send that out
to you to say thanks for being on and
doing your debt
free scream i'm so proud of you you're a
rock star well done
thank you dave all right kendra in san
antonio texas
59 000 paid off in
five years making 32-52
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
a three two one
that is how it works right there that is
impressive over five years that's a long
time to sacrifice that's a long time to
stay motivated that's a long time to
stay focused like
two years is long but five years man
that's impressive that she stuck with it
that's awesome
and you know the good news when you're
working this stuff and you're single is
you don't talk anybody else into it the
bad news is there's nobody there to kick
your butt no accountability yeah nobody
there to encourage you when you're down
yeah and nobody nobody to hold you in
there and
i mean she did that over five years
and her only accountability was
encouragement was her family
walking with her but i mean it's easier
to cheat when you're single
yes and to just give up on the plan
you're like oh this is too hard
i've done it for a period of time i've
made progress but gosh it's just i just
want to buy the shoes like she said and
she just stuck with it that's just so
awesome
that's very well done very very well
done that is awesome stuff
zach is with us zach is in rockford
illinois hi zach welcome to the ramsay
show
and thank you dave christie nice to be
talking with you how are you guys doing
better than we deserve what's up well i
am on baby step two and i am debating on
whether or not i should refinance my
house
or sell it and move back into an
apartment so i don't have to worry about
any home repairs
do you have home repairs you expect are
there things your maintenance issues
right now
so right now not really anything like
major i mean my furnace is about 15
years
water heater's five i just had to pay
for
a chimney flashing repair but it's an
older house
so that's kind of where i'm currently
debating i mean i've been in it for two
years if i would have taken
financial peace university before i
bought the home
i wouldn't have bought the home but i
took it four months after
but now with the market why would you
have not bought the home after financial
peace because of where you were in the
baby steps or because it's a bad buy
where i was in the baby steps it was
actually a pretty decent buy
at the current time i'm saying why would
you have not
bought the home you said if you took
financial peace university first you
would not have bought it did i
understand you're right
yeah you're saying that i i would i
wouldn't have bought it because i was in
debt
oh i see he's in babysitting yeah yeah
okay that's what i meant yeah all right
cool all right so but now you're out and
you're working on the house right
uh no no i'm still in baby step two so i
got seventy two thousand dollars
in student loans um and with the market
the way it is
i have twenty thousand dollars of equity
in the house
just because of the market so i'm trying
to figure out if i should
sell or refinance
why would you refinance so i
am currently in a 30 year so um
you know i would have did that
differently back then but it's at 4.25
okay um and after talking to mortgage
broker
uh i could probably get a 2.8 to a 3
interest rate yeah if you're gonna stay
in the house you're going to stay in the
house get in touch with churchill
mortgage and do a refi
because you can you can get down under
three right now on a 15 year fixed
while you're at it put it on a 15. um
how old are you i am 27.
and what do you make a year did you tell
me already i have
not i'm currently on pace for 60 to 65
so i'm in sales
so how much is your house commission
right now it's 6.46 it wouldn't move a
lot off of that because you're going to
drop 2
down but you're going to kick from a 30
to 15. it'll move up a little but not
much
yeah it's only about a hundred dollars
more yeah
um the house is the last
thing we sell i'll sell your car in a
heartbeat your boat and a heartbeat your
motorcycle and a heartbeat
they're easier to get out of and into
moving
is emotionally and financially very
expensive
it just takes up a lot of your head
space to move
and um so it's the last thing i would do
and i have a sense that you're just
starting
your financial peace journey am i right
i started about two years ago but you
guys were just mentioning the single
part
uh so i slowed down a little bit but i
re-kicked everything into gear i'm now
throwing
two thousand dollars a month towards
debt yeah um so
are you are you are you asking about
selling because you just want to make a
big huge dent
in your debt like is that where the
questions coming from
yeah and just not having any stress with
like the repairs would be on the
apartment complex i mean i did the map
of
you know also considering the water bill
and the electricity
yeah well let me tell you over the scope
of your life you can do the math
renting does not keep up with owning
owning is better even with the chimney
flashing
okay over the scope of your life not a
short-term situation sometimes
owning will be more expensive than
renting uh
so i think you've just had a repair and
you've got a re
uh juvenated desire to get out and those
two things are combining to push you to
sell it i'm gonna tell you to keep it
for now
uh in the spring next year if you're
still
limping with this thing a little bit you
may want to sell it but i think you're
going to refinance it and keep it
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we take your calls
about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two mason is with us mason is in lansing
michigan hi mason how are you
ada how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um so i'm 22 years old and i'm currently
living in my parents
house and i want to achieve financial
freedom
through entrepreneurship or starting a
self-storage business and i have five
thousand dollars saved up and i don't
know what to do with my next step
a self what business storage
storage self storage well that's a bit
of an expensive transaction dude let's
talk about buying a big piece of
commercial real estate
uh probably not your first step
i'm curious i'm curious mason why why
that out of curiosity
um i know uh a few people in my family
who
they have had success in there um
they're distant relatives so i don't
have a lot of contact with them
but um i know that they have made
a decent amount of money off of that oh
it's a cash cash once you get it up and
get it running it's a cash cow but we're
talking about
you know whatever it takes a half
million million dollars to get this
thing planted in the ground baby
i mean this is no small step here that
that's usually something you would do
after you've gotten something else going
so your drive is just to make money
right now
um to practically yeah
yeah so you said entrepreneurship what
are you thinking of there
um i'm i'm not sure i've looked into
quite a few uh different sections
but i i haven't landed like pinpointed
myself in a direction yet
what do you get excited about like what
what kind of things get you excited
because
the self-storage business while it's not
a bad idea that you want to
make money and your family has done it
uh business can be hard
and so looking deeper for a deeper
passion
than just money and success those things
will come what what are you passionate
about what are you excited about what
what
what keeps you up at night because you
man that's so fun i want to work on that
i want to help these people i want to
solve this problem that's
that's the heart of entrepreneurship is
solving problems and helping people
what is that for you um
well i do i do like before i got onto
the entrepreneurship
uh trail i was a mechanic
and i love working on cars and helping
out people that way
okay what have you been doing up to this
point
what kind of work um well like i said i
was uh
i was a mechanic but djakovic i got laid
off and i've been working at a
local grocery store stocking shelves i
make about
16 an hour i love your ambition
uh as a serial entrepreneur myself i
started cutting grass when i was 12
years old had 27 yards to cut i've
always had a p l in my life
uh and so i love what you're trying to
do i love where your head's at christy
teaches
uh men and women all over the world how
to start and how to operate businesses
is what she does she's excellent at it
um and i think both of us are stepping
back and going
uh let me let me ask you this have you
ever been someplace
and a salesman was trying to sell you
something
and it felt slimy
yes like he was there trying to make a
commission and didn't care about you
yes yeah that's what an entrepreneur is
that starts a business
just to make money
you smell bad and you don't mean for it
to mason
it doesn't start out you don't no but
you're you're in it for you
instead of them and so what you've got
to figure out is
is there has to be a problem that you're
looking
for in the world that god put you on the
planet to solve that problem for people
and it could be the most honest
uh mechanic in the world and you end up
owning a hundred
shops all over america with your name on
them fixing cars 10 years from now i
don't know
it could be something else but somewhere
there's a problem
that when you solve it for someone it
clicks in your soul and
makes you smile oh and i can make money
not i'll do anything to make money
because let me tell you that that i'll
do anything to make money is what's
driving the storage thing
you had no passion about that at all all
you're wanting to do is get some money
and we could hear in your voice
you're just trying to get some money and
that's never going to work
business business people who just try to
get money smell bad
it's when things get hard because they
will get hard you're going to give up
because that's not enough to keep you
going
let me give you a couple areas of your
life to look at mason as you explore
this
what are your strengths these are things
you're naturally good at what are your
skills any education experience the car
mechanic would be an example of
experience
what stuff do you have do you have
certain equipment you could use or a
laptop or a certain facility you can use
for a business idea
what would it was social what would you
do socially just for fun what would you
do as a hobby just because you love it
just because you enjoy it
look at your story your backstory is
there something that man you had a
a really tough season of life or
something you went through that that
could inspire a passion
for helping people my mom starting a
bakery when i was six months old
is part of my story that's my passion
behind business boutique
look at your skills your strengths your
stuff your story
your uh what you would do socially and
look at some of these things you already
have in you
to try to dig out in mind for what is
something that is a business idea i
could get excited about and don't get
overwhelmed by their there's only one
idea
just start with an idea that could work
try some stuff and see what works but
you need to be excited about it if
you're going to stick with it for the
long haul
and if you're not going to feel salesy
and desperate
for money which is what dave was talking
about so start with some of those i call
them my s's these are my
my five s's start with some of those s's
and let that
give you direction for maybe a business
idea that you'd be more excited about
than the storage right now and more cost
effective by the way
now nothing smells quite as bad as a
broke sales person or a greedy
salesperson
and when you open a business and you're
all about what money you can extract
from the customer that's the spirit
you're operating in
and that's what you want to avoid and
the problem is there's nothing evil
about wanting to
be ambitious and wanting to win and
going want to go i'm going to want to
start a business i'm going to go in the
marketplace and succeed
i want you to do all of that but what is
the problem that you're going to solve
that we
can't keep you from doing it once you
get lit on fire
i mean when i started doing the very
first thing i ever did with money was i
was just counseling people at our church
as a ministry for free helping people
that were in foreclosure stop a
foreclosure help them get on a budget
after
we went broke i had a heart for hurting
people
right that were where sharon and i had
been and i had the skills to stop
to help them right and i was doing it
for free right uh you couldn't keep me
from doing it yeah
and uh you know now it's a 350 million
dollar business
right you know and uh but it started
with that and that's also why
i can't be canceled because i won't stop
yeah i don't need someone's approval
to do this i don't need someone's
admiration
to do this i don't even need their money
to do this i'll just go
i'm gonna do it anyway i'm just gonna do
it yeah and then what that does is it
pierces through the darkness and pierces
through the bs
yeah that is out there in business but
the first time you hit a hard road block
like christy said
folks out there running a business you
quit yeah if
if you if you're not if your butt's not
burning if you ain't got this thing in
your stomach or you're just wired up man
and you just can't be denied you i'm
going you know
it's not about me being rich no that's a
by-product
yeah and i think people miss it because
they focus on what they get
not on what they give business and life
by the way is focusing on what you give
you give value solutions help to people
i see this all the time dave at our
events i'll have someone come through my
book signing line and they'll say
i want to do what you do i want to be a
speaker and every time i'll say
why because if if they don't have an
answer like i want to help these people
i want to solve these problems then
they're in it for the spotlight they're
in it for the followers doing it for the
fame
they want the admiration your audience
will feel that you can tell the
difference between a speaker who walks
on a stage
and they're looking for what they can
get i can i get a laugh can i get a
standing ovation
versus a speaker that comes on stage and
says i want to give value i want to give
solutions and it's the same
in business if you are in it for what
you can get
your customers will feel it and if
you're in it for what you can give
your customers will feel it our friend
ken blanchard says profit
is the applause that your customers give
you
well done well done
that's what they're saying it's a
byproduct of it mason that's a really
good question i'm so glad you called in
to ask it
and you probably got more than you
bargained for but uh
i i i predict good things in your future
sir you're a sharp young man
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker
just tell alexa google assistant or siri
to play the ramsay show podcast check
out all ramsay network shows on your
smart speaker today
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where dad is dumb
cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host christy wright
ramsey personality number one best
selling author of the book business
boutique and host of the christy wright
podcast which is
a big exploding movement i is my co-host
today as we answer your questions the
phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight
eight two five five two two
five ryan is with us to start off this
hour in
waterbury connecticut hey ryan how are
you
good dave how you doing better than i
deserve sir what's up
um i'm 27 years old and i'm on baby
steps four and six
and i was wondering if it would be
ridiculous or
wise to stop making extra payments on my
mortgage
to save up and build a basketball court
in my backyard
a basketball court in your backyard
what does it look like a real court like
like not just like a goal like an actual
court
yeah like a concrete slab oh my
like a a full court or half a car
do a half half a half okay
um what would it cost
uh between three and six grand
and um what uh
what do you make a year uh
last year i made 65 but this year i'm
looking to make closer
to 85. what's your house worth
uh 228. okay and you just love that i'm
just curious why you just love
basketball you want to play all the time
yeah or is this just kind of like a
ridiculous thing to do
because i'm trying to be wise you know
and build wealth and i was planning on
paying the house off within five to
seven years
um but other than that i was just
curious on you know i mean it's no it's
not ridiculous i mean people put tennis
courts in their backyard
people put pools in their backyard they
do all kinds of things
let's talk about it from a real estate
perspective no it's not ridiculous but
let's talk through is there a
is there a better way to do this than a
and a worse way to do this and the
answer is yeah i think there is probably
from a real estate person's perspective
is how i'm going to put that
hat on for a minute um yeah
i'm going to build it if i if i'm doing
this the
for the least money possible number one
because it's not going to add a dime of
value to the house
right so like if you spend six thousand
dollars the house is not worth six
thousand dollars more because of it
as a matter of fact if you do it poorly
the house might be less
marketable because it's kind of got this
weird thing in the backyard for somebody
that doesn't play basketball
right that's what i was that's what i
was worried about down the line
like i looked at a really nice vacation
property the other day
that like a super super nice one i don't
play
tennis and it had a fabulous tennis
court in the backyard
and i kind of looked at that as a
negative not a positive
it's like a thing back there that i
don't need or want
and you know it's like a like a problem
not a not an opportunity so
that's a if you do it wrong that's how
you do it so depending on how you're
i mean i'm just thinking about
properties that i've owned or lived in
number one growing up in nashville we
had
turn arounds that they that you back out
of the garage
and you drive away and most of the
neighborhood kids including
when my kids were little we had a nice
turnaround that was paved in our case it
wasn't concrete
and we put a basketball goal on the
house or put one on a pole
on the edge of the turnaround and it
didn't really
a cost anything extra to put the actual
surface in
it was a little bit of money to put a
goal up uh but b
it didn't weird people out there weren't
basketball people when they came to buy
the house they just went well i'll take
the pole down right if i don't like one
i don't want it back
and so do you have like a turnaround you
could do that with
i don't but my other idea was to
build a patio on the back of the house
you know
closer to the house and it would be a
smaller patio but also
i could play basketball on it and then
that would be the same kind of
thing that makes a lot more sense and
then you you know and then the buyer can
visualize i'm just gonna pull the goal
out
or you could even pull the goal out
yourself before you put it on the market
and then you've just got a nice patio
you built
now we're not messing with the
marketability of the house okay and that
is less weird uh the only other thing i
can think of is
i don't again a driveway uh
configuration matters here
but if you don't have a turnaround if
you have a uh
your driveway pulls up and you can
simply extend the driveway back and put
the pad
there it gives additional parking spaces
or maybe a slab
to put an extender or to put a a
an exterior garage on some day if it
wasn't a basketball court that kind of
thing so we've got again like like the
patio thing it's got multiple uses right
so i i just want you thinking that way
don't stick it back there and make it a
problem for the buyer
how long are you planning to stay in
this house out of curiosity
uh well i wanted to pay it off as soon
as possible
and that looks about five to seven years
and then my plan was to either
use it as a rental or you know resell it
and move up in house
gotcha okay okay so yeah yeah i think
you just
use some of these ideas we're batting
around here and try to make it a
a multi-use type of thing yeah where
it's got possible other uses so it
doesn't just look like a
problem concrete slab in the backyard
yeah yeah like
why is that there i wanted to grow
tomatoes there
you know and you know that that's what
people will that's what that stinking
tennis court i mean
i think it's wonderful if you play
tennis but i don't play tennis well and
even can i turn it into a shooting ring
the thing is the percentage of people
that might buy your house that like
basketball is small
and then the people that would want to
play is even smaller than the people
that would want that in their backyard
is like
tiny yeah so you're talking about a very
small percentage of people that someone
would actually like that so the rest of
the people you're isolating
build it in such a way that it can be
something else yeah
in addition to that and the least
possible cost
as well because you're not doing that
and then and the more you move in that
direction
the less you are on the ridiculous side
and the more you are on the wise side
there you go good question interesting
chuck's with us in kansas city hi chuck
how are you
i'm doing good thanks dude yeah i i i'm
57
and i just came into some money and i
was wanting to invest it
for retirement and one of the options i
looked at was
indexed annuities and i was curious what
you thought about
that option it's okay
i wouldn't use it for an actual
retirement account because an annuity
grows tax deferred
and a retirement account also grows tax
deferred so it's kind of redundant
in that sense or tax-free if it's a roth
and you're paying an extra fee for it to
be in the annuity
so you just buy the index you buy an
index mutual fund
inside of your roth if you were going to
do that uh um
the other thing i want you to be aware
of is i don't i'm 60 and i don't use
them
uh because they've got extra fees the
commissions are much higher on them for
the uh
seller uh the the financial advisor
that's selling them than a simple mutual
fund transaction
and so instead what i do with a lump sum
like that is i invest it just in an
index fund
i use an s p 500 index fund i just drop
some money in there
and it grows without taxes by and large
until you take it out because it's
capital gains growth
it is not uh dividend growth and they
have what's called a low turnover ratio
so study and learn a little bit about
low turnover ratio mutual funds
that would be my suggestion but the
variable in od as long as it's got good
mutual funds in it is not horrible
in your situation
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
here at ramsey solutions we want to
transform so
many lives that disruption
spreads like wildfire across this
country if you haven't noticed our
culture has become toxic and the only
way to remove that toxicity
is to displace it with clean
good real ideas imagine a world where
it's weird to have a student loan
that you get an education and you pay
for it imagine a world where the
majority people pay cash
for their car imagine a world where the
credit card is the cigarette of the
financial world
imagine a world where ladies
are empowered and know exactly how to
start and run their businesses the way
christy teaches
at ramsey solutions we work on this
level of disruption
every day and it's why we have a just
under a thousand folks on our team right
now
and they create digital products and
services to help people transform their
lives with the goal of disrupting
the toxic culture in america today
and if you want to join us on that
crusade we're currently on the hunt for
software engineers with expertise in
ruby on rails
java c-sharp end technologies if you're
a ux designer
an seo content marketing specialist
uh digital creative we'd love to talk
with you
we've got about 300 jobs we need to fill
this
year to be able to do the different
initiatives
that we've got to help people in america
today
if you want to talk about joining us
find out about all the available jobs by
texting
work that matters to 33 789
text work that matters to 33789 to find
out about our open opportunities
and you can of course also go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the
right hand tab that says
we are hiring lucy is in california hi
lucy welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve how can christy and i help
so i actually just started listening to
you about a week and a half ago
and um i started the cash envelope
system and started budgeting because i
am a horrible horrible spender
so i want to change my habits i do have
a student loan
for about 37 000 that i haven't made a
payment
to since 2017
and i also have a title loan
that i pay about 96 interest and
my principal balance is about 5 000.
um i just because i am
sort of new to this uh budgeting
and i'm trying to be debt free i just
want your advice on how to attack
um these loans that i have because i i
do have a
six-month-old baby that i want to plan
for for her future
good for you so you're a single mom
um no i have a boyfriend okay
all right so you're a single mom okay
okay
and uh i mean you're not married right
no we're not married
okay and uh what do you make of your
55 000 and that's good news
well congratulations on stepping up and
saying hey this is an area of my life
that's caused me pain and i want to fix
it i'm proud of you yeah
thank you very very well done very cool
stuff good for you
so um having sat in this seat
for almost 30 years now here's what i
think i heard you say
in the background behind the words um
how old are you 33
okay and so you've kind of just lived
your life
and money happened to you you never
happened
to it and the baby comes and you went oh
crap i got to be a grown-up
yeah is that right yeah okay
good for you i'm so proud of you yeah
that's awesome thank you thank you so
much
and i can tell some of that because the
the only way anybody takes out a title
loan is they're desperate
yeah you felt cornered at some point and
out of money and scared
because otherwise you wouldn't have
signed up for 96 interest
everyone knows including you that that
that's not a winning proposition right
yeah no so the great news about your
story is is that once you
once the switch flipped inside your
brain in the last few months
uh and you said no more i've had it i'm
not living like this anymore
you're going to change things fast so
fast it's going to be amazing
because you're so ready i don't have to
talk you into stuff you're like over it
am i is that right yes i am okay
completely well obviously then what
we're going to do is we're going to get
on a detailed type budget
beans and rice rice and beans no life i
don't want you going out to eat i don't
want to hear about a vacation
you have a mess girl and it's time to
clean it up and we're going to do
our whole life right now is clean up
debt complete focused intensity
like okay
okay all right and the first thing we're
gonna do is we're gonna get rid of this
stupid butt
title loan and get those people out of
your life and don't you ever go back on
that property
or call those people ever again the rest
of your life
okay i won't i won't ever in fact you
can take your pinky out and
wave it at them as you drive by every
time from now on
because i am never going to go in this
place again they screw people
right no they do for sure and i i know
this
because i am in the financial industry
myself
but i yeah yeah well you had a brain
lapse because you got desperate every
time i get desperate right after
that i get stupid that's what happens to
me it happens to me too and
i teach this stuff so we're going to
attack that thing we're going to be on a
detailed written budget
i'm going to put you into ramsey plus
for one year it's our online access to
everything it's the cadillac the bentley
all right it's going to put you into
financial peace university into the uh
extended version of every dollar the
world's best budgeting app
i'm going to pay for all of it it's
going to be free for you
but you have to promise me you're going
to get in there and do everything we
tell you to do
and one year from today you're going to
have a completely different life if you
do that
oh my god yes
i told you she was ready yeah
you're awesome i am so proud of you so
you go through financial peace
university you drag boyfriend in there
by the ear
and uh tell him he's gonna watch it with
you and we're gonna start getting our
act together and get our life together
and
get this stress off of you okay you're
gonna do this lucy and when you do i
want you to call us back
and you tell us your story and you do
your debt-free scream okay
oh my god yes you're gonna get actually
we've been binge watching on youtube
i've been listening to your podcast
and um he has a sprained ankle right now
so he was stuck with me in my room all
day yesterday while i was working
and i said i'm going to play this
because this is what i've been listening
to while i work
and he's also been so motivated and he's
like wow this just
puts you like in the right mind like you
know we want to buy a house
and want to start a savings for our baby
girl so
i mean i think he's he's better with his
money than i am but
um i'm so ready for this thank you guys
so much you don't even know
how much i appreciate this well we are
honored to help you
it's what we do and you hang on kelly
will pick up we'll get you signed up and
you call us back anytime you need help
while you're walking through this
and call us back and when you score the
touchdown and let us know and we'll do
your debt-free scream with you how fun
that is so cool i love that her
boyfriend was a captive audience and
she's like your ankle is sprained i'm
just going to play the dave ramsey
show for you while you're stuck you
can't
please hey that's going to be our new
answer of how to get people to break
their
pages break their ankle hobble them
hobble them and they can't how do i get
my spouse
on board you hit their ankle with a
sledgehammer and then just press play
that's great i love it that's awesome
les brown the great motivator
i was i did an event with him about i
was walking through the hallway my
picture with him back here the other day
and i stopped and looked at it because
he's such a good man he lives over in
l.a
and um he just says you have to be
hungry
you know you have to be sick and tired
of being sick and tired
and people change their lives when they
say i've had it
i've had it i've had it and you know
what no amount of intellect offsets that
no no amount of academic discussion of
some
freaking theory offsets that you have to
get this
belly-burning thing happening where you
go that's
it i'm not living like this anymore this
sucks
and when you change that that's when it
changes
your my favorite quote of you is you can
wander into debt you cannot wander out
you got to get mad i love it you got to
get fired up man
and it's just a decision and that's
where lucy is she just decided
and then we stumbled across her path how
serendipitous
thank you lord
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
as we talk to you about your life and
your money in the lobby of ramsey
solutions
on the debt-free stage baby they're here
nick and brody are with us uh which can
only mean one thing they're debt free
hey guys
hi hi christy hi dave hi where do you
guys live
nome alaska wow quite a trek
you win the furthest travel for a debt
free scream award
oh my gosh wow very cool and any excuse
to get down south huh
right it was negative 30 with wind chill
when we left
which is unseasonably cold but wow can't
breathe we're melting man well i'm so
glad you're here how much do you pay
off 267
845 dollars wow
how long did that take well
um it took nine and a half years okay
and your range of income during that
decade
we started off at 75 000 went up to 150
and then down to 124. okay
what kind of debt was this i'm guessing
with that length of time and that amount
of money you might have paid off your
house
we did wow look at the weird people
oh how old are you two weird people i
was
35 when we paid it off we paid it off uh
three weeks before my 36th birthday
there you go
and i'm 39. ding ding well done you guys
what do you do in gnome alaska i'm a
court administrator
and i work for an airline okay very cool
now i've been to anchorage where is
gnome i can't see it in my head
it's uh northwest of anchorage about 500
miles oh just a wee bit
you can only of anchorage alaska where
do you live
north of anchorage yes okay that'll work
wow
okay yeah well you can only fly half the
places in alaska i heard you have more
airline uh there are more people that
have airline light air
pilot slices than driver's license might
be true
yeah i've heard that so wow man very
cool so what's this house worth
two hundred and twenty thousand dollars
was what we paid for it
yeah it's at least 260 now yeah yeah
very good
and was the 268 all the mortgage or
other things too
we had about 47 000 in consumer debt
when we first started
um paid that all off and in about seven
months
and then we uh lived life for a while
and
after paying uh off that debt we moved
we uh cash flowed that move um
we bought a house
sold a house we saved for the down
payment for
this house and then in 2015 we bought
this house
and uh we really weren't
focused on paying it off like we were
doing our budget every month
and uh we were throwing extra at the
principal but
i don't think either of us nick brought
home a thermometer
for us to fill in every time we paid it
off we'd fill it in a little bit much
a lot of people do that but it takes on
a new meaning in nome alaska
well when nick brought it home it just
felt overwhelming
it just was there was a lot of lines
right
it didn't seem like we were making much
progress on it
and i think when it really kicked in
was december of 2018
when we decided to throw a chunk of
money at it
and we were at the halfway mark
and i can see the light like oh we can
do this
and um before um we really became
focused around three and a half years
ago when our daughter was born our
oldest
and we're like why are we just you know
we're not really focused on the house
we're doing all these other things
buying gear there's so much gear that
you can buy for things in alaska
and snow machines snow machines and
four-wheeler
i mean just you name it and it's all
expensive it's not
cheap and so we'd been cash flowing
those different things and then when our
daughter was born we were like
um at different times before that we'd
kind of look at each other and be like
are you ready to pay off really focus
and one of us would be like no look
squirrel i want that thing over there
let's do that thing then we'll do it
yeah then we'll do it but once our
daughter was born we really dug in
and uh and we paid it off in february of
this year
so how does it feel to be 35 39 years
old with a paid for house
i don't know if it's really sunk in yet
we just paid it off in february and so
april 1st was our first budget meeting
where we didn't have a mortgage payment
for march or april and so that i think
it's starting to sink in but we're not
we haven't fully realized it's a lot of
money yeah
yeah it's a lot of money wow good for
you
i'm so proud of you thanks very cool who
are your biggest cheerleaders
oh man you know we were pretty private
about the journey
we've certainly talked to our friends
about it and um
the friends that we've talked to have
all been
like wow you guys are doing it that's
awesome and
but um our parents have been supportive
my mom's taken financial peace
university we've taught a couple
financial
um university courses thank you um so
that keeps you on track it really did
when you start teaching it you have to
do it
yeah you could go to the class and sort
of do it but when you teach it you have
to do it
yeah it forced us to do an insurance
double check
oh there you go yeah we had some
updating to do on all that too
yeah very good very good what do you
tell people the secret to getting out of
debt is
for me with the house it was really
patience
because we had you know been cash
flowing things for a while and
having that large number and just
breaking it down into small chunks and
being able to
just be patient and wait um yeah how do
you eat an elephant a bite
right yeah that thermometer one line at
a time
yeah that's so interesting too because
research shows that seeing progress
is the most motivating thing and once
you guys got to the halfway mark like it
gave you that extra push so it's just so
cool to see how
those small things all added up to you
guys sticking with it
well done that's amazing yeah you just
won't you won't stick with it if you
don't see the progress
and that's good the incremental wins
that's so good you guys
whoo-hoo you did it you are a debt-free
house and everything
completely so weird i love it
and you brought the kiddos with you to
do the debt-free screen what are their
names and ages
this is lydia she is three and a half
years old
sweet and this is adrian
she turned one a week after we paid off
the house
wow that's awesome we've got a pretty
lydia in our family too
not much older than that oh yeah very
cool you guys congratulations we've got
a copy of rachel cruz's
book for you her latest new york times
bestseller know yourself know your money
nick and brody and lydia and adrian
268 000 paid off in nine and a half
years
75 to 150 to 124 house and everything
they
are weird count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one we're debt-free
good job you guys this is how it's done
that's so cool wow it was like just the
joy
it was just like you could feel it oh my
gosh well what people don't realize
is when you don't have that payment it's
a math thing for a while it's kind of an
emotional thing for a while
but when it's gone it's a spiritual
thing yeah you feel something
click in the spirit you know and you're
like
i had no idea i was a slave and now i'm
not
yeah the borrower is slave to the lender
there's something
yeah the freedom in that there's a
release yeah like that breath of cold
mountain air
yeah you probably don't use cold air in
their example with gnome alaska but
yeah there's a sense of cleanliness
going down into your lungs you know i
mean there's this like i'm
wow i'm in a whole different place yeah
because you are yeah yeah you're set up
to win and that's just the first step
that's right you're living like no one
else so that later you can live
and give like no one else so you can put
yourself in a position to win like
you've
never done before and completely changed
those babies family tree
what great what a great young couple
rock stars that's awesome that is so
fun this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsay it's magic
you'll get the best
deal today's question comes from shelly
in ohio
i'm a 52 year old woman with a ba in art
and mba in management i've been a stay
at home mom for the last 10 years but
i'm ready to go back to work
i'd love to get into interior design
however most jobs require
design training which i don't have our
community college offers a two-year
course and i can cash flow their program
is this something worth doing at my age
this is such an interesting question and
i think there's some different
variables that i want to point out first
of all at her age i'm like
absolutely you can do that if you want
to and you can cashflow but what's more
interesting to me is
if you think you want to do it i
encourage people to do this a lot
how can you get some experience in that
to make sure you want to do it before
you go take the courses because even if
you have to have some
education and training in this to do you
know a full
interior design full-time job it doesn't
mean you have to have that in order to
get started or to intern or to shadow or
to
have some position where you could make
sure this is what you want to do
before you do it so i would encourage
maybe a baby step but as far as her age
i'm like no you absolutely
can do that people switch careers they
have encore careers what's the example
of the um
colonel sanders the connection 63 years
old before he ever um
fried his first chicken brought his
first chicken yeah yeah not no i mean
there's a lot of
grandma moses never paid a painting
until she was 88 years old she did 1500
works of art before she died at 100.
and so you're not done do you quit don't
talk to me about your age you're 52 i'm
60 you're pissing me off
so you're not done here you're not done
but the um
you know the thing on interior design
there's so many ways to get at that
and there are many many many world-class
designers who never had a class on
interior design
they just they had an eye for it a knack
for it and they developed it
over time they studied with and around
other people but they didn't necessarily
go get a degree
in interior design there's a lot of them
uh that do very very well and and you've
got an mba in business so you know to
run the business part
uh so i i i'm with you i think i would
use that ken coleman proximity principle
and let's find an interior designer in
your area and
even if uh you did something really
weird uh you're not making any money
right now
so why don't you just go work for them
for free for 90 days and say i want to
prove that i'm worth having me around
uh and then work for them for a year and
learn how they do what they do
you're probably going to figure out that
you can pick fabric
yeah without a two-year degree that's
probably gonna figure out you can pick a
paint color
without a two-year degree and maybe
maybe there's some for example maybe
there's some program that a lot of
interior designers use
to mock up what a room would look like
to present to a potential client you
learn that on the job or you learn that
in this uh
company that you don't have to go get a
degree to do anyway so even if there is
some technical aspect that you want to
know that would help you
you might be able to just learn it there
yeah almost in an apprentice
type of a setting use that proximity
principle yeah i'm with you i think i'd
get my feet wet
um i don't think what you need is more
education i think you need some
confidence
that's right you're looking for
confidence and it's not found in
education
it's amazing how many people ask me such
a similar question dave
of well i need to go get another degree
and another degree and another degree
and what they're really looking for is
permission they're waiting for
some piece of paper that's going to give
them permission like you don't need
permission
to go do this thing to go try this thing
to go help people and learn
the the degree you think is going to be
your gateway of permission and
more often than not it's you actually
doing the thing that makes you feel the
confidence you're looking for
you have a four-year degree in art if
you decide you're an interior designer
you just are one
you just decided that's right i should
print you some business cards baby
that's right
and then go pick some paint colors and
will you get better over time yeah will
you stumble around a little bit yeah
you don't know how to necessarily source
the lines of furniture or the fabrics or
the paintings or whatever is needed
to decorate that home and make it look
like magazine city but
i think you probably know enough to
start today
but if you want to build a little
confidence go work for somebody for a
little bit
and and getting your feet wet will give
you not only the confidence but it'll
give you the skills
dave i think i took one class in college
on speaking and that's just because it
was a part of
my business management program you know
how i learned how to be a speaker is by
speaking for the last 10 years yeah
and and reviewing and every time you did
a talk
watching the video and looking at
surveys that sucked learning watching
from other people
it's just brutal to watch yourself yes
it is you know you go back and review
your own work
in any work you'll find the errors more
than anybody else will find them and
you'll correct course correct course
great get better get better get better
that's called experience and um but you
know how you become a writer you're
right that's right
you know you become a speaker you speak
you know how you become an interior
designer you and do interior design
that's right
and uh so i i there's not a license
required
uh you don't need permission you can
just go but if you need
more confidence then
uh we've decorated oh i can't think
i can't count now thoroughly decorated
and or
redecorated using five different
decorators
over the years uh or interior designers
over the years
and some of them with uh big-time
credentials some of them without
uh but you know what we cared about we
didn't care a thing about their
credentials what we cared about was
the work that they had done and we're
going to do can you do a good job
and can i get there and that's all i
cared about yeah i didn't know
you know as a matter of fact i kind of
preferred they didn't have
a long list of letters after their name
from
some school in france because that means
they're going to charge me triple to
pick to go i need a white wall while i
already knew you needed a white wall
you know i mean so don't you know i just
i i didn't
you know it was less joy for me that way
more joy for sharon probably but less
joy for me
so uh and that's not to say you can't
learn things from
um in that field but but um
but getting started is probably your
best bet yeah it's good it's a big deal
melissa is in boise idaho hi melissa
welcome to the ramsay show thank you hi
dave and christie
hi um hi i moved from california to
idaho in 2017 and now i have a job i
really love but i kept my house in
california and i
plan to retire in four years and maybe
move back
but what i'm thinking now is should i
keep the house for the whole four years
sell it and then put it into an
investment property
and then just and pay cash for it and
let it cash flow
and then i just ran and live around and
travel around or is it better to just
have that as my primary residence or
would you recommend i didn't sell it now
i'd show it now
like that because you i wouldn't long
distance landlord for 20 seconds
it's a nightmare and i don't know i
don't know i own a bunch of rental
property and i don't recommend it
i just i don't recommend it and i don't
know what california real estate is
going to do
it has done well in the past obviously
it has also been in my lifetime of 40
years
working lifetime of 40 years watching
real estate it has been the most
volatile market overall
meaning it goes way up and then it busts
and goes way up and then it busts
and with the number of people leaving
that state right now
i don't know what's going to happen to
prices there
i'm a little shocked honestly with the
level of the level of
exodus from california that prices
haven't already gotten soft there
uh but they haven't they're having it
they're white hot they they're quite hot
yeah so
no inventory yeah yeah no it's no
inventory we're in the united states i
mean uh
so the covington even though even though
you'd pay recapture right now because if
i
right now i'm using it as my primary and
paying california taxes and my
doing a roommate situation and gave them
reduced rent
and i think if i wait until january to
sell it i won't have to pay fifty six
thousand recapture or would you just
take that if you wait till january and
say fifty six thousand i'll wait until
january but i'm not gonna keep it five
years and
you know i wouldn't have kept it in the
first place and so i'm gonna begin the
process of divesting
and saying you know i'm going to live in
idaho my investments are going to be in
idaho and when i leave idaho my
investments will also leave idaho
and um that that's what i would have you
to do
um it's not it's all
almost never i mean so close to never
that i can just say never
a good idea to become a landlord by
default
in other words would you have gone and
bought that house to use it as rental
property while you lived in idaho
answer 1 thousand times is no
i live in idaho i'm gonna go to buy a
house that looks like something i would
live in in california
for rental no you wouldn't do that and
so since you wouldn't do that then
keeping it is becoming a landlord by
default and it
seldom turns out to be a great decision
seldom
i mean can you get out of it make some
money yeah yeah if you can
56 000 help on the recapture by january
fine i'm good with that
but but long term i'm not holding that
puppy thank you for the call
christy good show thanks so much thanks
for having me this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage may mean you're
an everyday millionaire
it's an everyday millionaires theme hour
we want you to call in if you're a real
millionaire we're gonna talk to you this
hour
and for the rest of you we're going to
teach you what real millionaires do
not what your broke brother-in-law
thinks
and not what some idiot hack political
person
with an axe to grind who wants us to
move towards socialism thinks
we're going to teach you where real
millionaires come from
spoiler alert you can do it
you can do it when you live like no one
else
later you can live as a millionaire
and give like no one else
now because there are political idiots
out there
uh and people who have entered the
conversation in the name of wealth
equality or
inequality or whatever the discussion
needs to be
with that we have to address a couple of
basic definitions
millionaire is an accounting term
you don't get to make up your own
definition there is a
singular one definition that is the
truth
a millionaire is not someone that makes
a million dollars a year
a millionaire is not someone that has a
million dollars cash
although that person could also be a
millionaire
millionaire refers to billionaire also
refers to net worth
your net worth is what you own
minus what you owe
now various people in different
accounting functions will
include some assets and don't include
some assets
i mean you can put your clothing in
there if you want but your clothing's
not really worth anything so that's a
bunch of crap
okay so but what do you actually own
that you can turn into money
and what do you owe what you own
minus what you owe your assets minus
your liabilities equals your net worth
when you do that in that bottom right
hand corner
that number is a million dollars or
greater you are a millionaire it's not a
feeling
i don't feel like a millionaire it
doesn't matter million dollars isn't
enough anymore
doesn't matter we're not discussing
feelings and we're not discussing what's
enough we're telling you how
you become a millionaire it's when you
have a 1 million
or greater net worth does it solve all
your problems
well crap no it actually brings you new
ones okay
does it but but one problem you don't
have is you can afford the tylenol for
the headache
okay one problem you don't have is you
don't have to worry about putting tires
on your car anymore
one problem you don't have is you're not
gonna retire and retire and count on
social insecurity to take care of your
butt
uh which is an absolute nightmare you
actually have some money that's what a
millionaire is
so we're going to talk to real
millionaires ask them what they did how
it's made up and how they got there
because there's a lot of mythology
around millionaires
the phone number here is triple eight
eight two five five
two two five i don't care how you became
a millionaire
i wanna talk to you because we wanna
tell real people what
real millionaires do how they did it
so that real people can say i want to do
it that way if all of you won the
lottery
then we'll all line up for the lottery
which by the way that isn't how it
worked okay
but you know whatever it is we want to
copy you millionaires so we can be one
of you
that's the purpose of this hour the
everyday
millionaire theme hour clint is our
first millionaire up
in chattanooga tennessee hi clint how
are you
i'm doing great dave how are you better
than i deserve what's your net worth
uh 1.3 million good for you
break that down for me by category how
much in your retirement how much in your
house and so forth
we've got about 620 000 in retirement
savings
we've got uh between our home and a
piece of land we own that's about 380
000
and we've got 300 000 in cash and
other savings good for you well done how
old are you
37 years old wow young millionaire so
how much of this did you inherit sir
none zero and what was your range of
income
your best working year and your worst
working year
uh best it would have been last year we
made about 225 000
um and worst would have been when we
first got married
we started at about 84 000. what do you
guys do for a living what do you do
i'm a vice president of a construction
company
in the estimating side and my wife she's
a
quality manager at a major carpet
manufacturer
gotcha and you have a four-year degree
we do we both have bachelor's degrees
okay what's your degree in
uh construction management and
brittany's is in industrial engineering
and
you're both using it good what's your
gpa what's your gpa in college uh we
were mid threes
nothing real good but nothing real bad
either gotcha okay
how much of this 1.3 million dollars in
net worth at 37 years old do you think
you have because you borrowed money to
create wealth
well i i learned about you uh my senior
year of college
and i've seen debt as the arch enemy of
wealth
since then so zero zero so you haven't
leveraged your way into this so to speak
okay no sir all right you did this
really quick
i'm very proud of you very impressive so
there's a 22 year old guy
who's in construction management
listening to you right now
how'd you do this in 15 years
what do you tell him well my my mom
was going through financial peace
university and handed me the cds
from the class and said you need to
listen to this guy um
and it clicked as soon as i listened to
it and
i would say probably uh the number one
thing would be choose your spouse wisely
um because uh yeah
right there i'm just saying yeah yeah
yeah
if you've got somebody that's willing to
lock arms with you and
claw great sacrifice to meet any goal
there's really nothing you can't do and
if you can eliminate the number one
cause of divorce in your marriage
early on then you know that the other
things are minuscule compared to that
so yeah that's so impressive that's very
very insightful
um okay so sometimes people think that
if you did this this quick
um that that you have had no life during
the last 15 years do you all go on
vacations and have you enjoyed your life
during the last 15 years
no absolutely there's there's portions
of the baby steps where
you know you're you're sacrificing the
fun of life
at times but we we do plenty of things
and
right now we do pretty much anything we
want to do yeah i guess so
man congratulations yeah you're making a
couple hundred thousand dollars a year
not a payment in the world a million
three net worth
37 so that means that my guesstimate is
you're probably going to be worth 10 to
20 million dollars at 65.
that would be the goal yeah that's kind
of mind-blowing
starting from nothing so it absolutely
can
be done that's the moral of the story
folks so there he is
a construction management guy he's not a
star in the nba
he doesn't have his own state farm
commercial
[Music]
you don't know his name
and at 37 years old he's worth 1.3
million dollars
i'm telling you folks you can do this
and i'm going to continue to show you
you can do it
and i'm going to continue to punch
people in the mouth that say you can't
do it
this is the ramsay show
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at backslash
chministries.org
we absolutely believe in it
it's an everyday millionaire theme hour
this is the ramsay show we're talking to
real
millionaires mythology is out there
about where wealth comes from in america
by the way you will hear on this show
and you will hear from the largest study
of millionaires ever done in north
america airtight research
that the vast majority of millionaires
did not
inherit their wealth as a matter of fact
79 percent of the millionaires were
inherited
zero another five percent inherited a
small amount like five thousand dollars
not enough to make any difference at
all towards becoming a millionaire and
another five percent
inherited money after they were already
millionaires so let me help you with
that 79
plus 10 is 89.
that's 9 out of 10 millionaires are not
millionaires
because of inherited money that's a
statistical fact not a fruit loop
writing a blog in his mother's basement
what's that matter it matters because
you
can do it is what this says and oh by
the way in the top five
uh professions teacher
was number three
in the largest study of millionaires
ever done webster's with us
in the lobby on the debt-free stage to
do is
to tell us about being an everyday
millionaire so where do you live here in
nashville
talahoma talahama just down the road
just down the road yeah i love it i've
got a lake house right down by
yeah you should do yeah cool stuff so
what's your net worth webster
1.4 million good for you and give me a
little breakdown on that
retirement real estate so forth uh 250
000
is the house 1 million dollars in
retirement
and then 200 000 in
cash and a taxable investment account
good for you well done how old are you
64.
great but then you're supposed to say
webster you don't look like yourself you
don't look like you're 64 webster
you you look like you're you look like
you're always you look like you're on
the 32nd anniversary
of your 32nd birthday and so um
what was your what's your range of
income in your working life your best
year working your worst year working
well worst year was when i first started
in it
in uh 1977 making a whopping 400
a month okay 4 800
a year yeah yeah all right up to a high
of
180 180. good for you way to go
very cool so how much of the 1.4 million
did you inherit
200 000 200 000 okay were you
already a millionaire when you got that
no so
we got out of debt uh september 2005
and then my in-laws were at their final
stages of life so we got some gifts
from them and then in 2008
my father-in-law passed we inherited the
house
that was paid for when we moved to
tulahoma
in august of 2008 we sold that paid for
house
so we got a hundred and something
thousand dollars for the house
then plus other gifts so from my wife's
side of the family we inherited
200 000 yeah 160 000 gotcha and then
when my parents passed uh we got about
another additional 40 000 but by that
time we were
millionaires okay but you almost were
before that then
yeah yeah okay all right cool so i i
think it it boosted you but i don't
think we say you
are a millionaire because of inherited
money no no
but it it definitely gave you a leg up
it def it started the the
the first uh money into
the first ira came from the gifts from
the in-laws cool and you said your
career was i.t i.t
okay very good very good and uh what was
your gpa
in college uh i have no degree no degree
zero degree so
high school education yes okay good for
you
and you wandered into i.t in the 70s and
have been self-taught since
yes and or courses or whatever right
yeah sure a lot of certificate a couple
hundred certifications
yeah i bet mainly because um i
listened to you i've been listening to
you since um
november 1999 and so over the years
listen to you listen to others
especially when entre leadership
started yeah invest in yourself yeah
invest in your skills
invest in your knowledge so when we
started
our so our we just had our 20-year
dave ramsey anniversary on march 25th
wow
so when we started i was making 36 000 a
year
okay and then over the four and a half
years that we paid off 197 thousand
dollars
uh our average income was 48 000. you
know there's an interesting insight
there and man i really appreciate the
history together and
um i'm proud of that that i'm proud of
you guys with what you've done
but here's the interesting insight this
idea that okay you ever just run a
calculation you say if you invest this
much a month you'll be a millionaire
you know if you just invest if you
invest a hundred dollars a month from
age 25 to age 65 at 12
it's one point it's 1 million 176 000
okay so 100
a month you know so that that'll make
you think about where you spend 100
bucks right
so you just run that but here's the
thing it's never that simple
yeah because what's happened is is the
only way your money grew was you
continued to grow
yes as a person yes it was a holistic
thing going on here your spiritual walk
your relationship
uh your marriage all of those things
have to continue to grow and blossom as
well
or the little math formula quits working
doesn't it yeah i mean you've grown you
faster than this money grew even
yes is what it amounts to that's
beautiful i love that
i have never seen that before that's a
very interesting insight
so what advice do you have to a 25 year
old techie that's out there
can they become a millionaire yes they
can
my advice to my 25 year old self
would have been to have listened to a
very wise
woman that i knew at the time mrs
campbell
she was day before dave's days
and her advice was always pay cash
never have debt always save
and always invest for your future and
always give
yes yeah and i wish my pig-headed
stubborn
obnoxious arrogant 20-something self
would have listened to her
yeah yeah this would be four million
[Laughter]
but you did okay webster you still got a
million for i'm so proud of you
congratulations sir you're living the
american dream thank you for taking time
very very nice brian is with us brian's
in raleigh north carolina brian what's
your net worth
uh 1.1 million days good for you give me
a little breakdown by category on that
how much retirement how much real estate
so forth
sure um i'm pretty real estate heavy um
i got about eight eight fifty in real
estate and then
the remainder of that would be in
retirement 401k
okay so like 300 in that then all right
yeah about that yep good for you how old
are you
uh 27. wow look at you dude
well done so all this real estate is
paid for
oh yes sir wow all right so tell me
about this what was your best year i
mean in the four years you've been
working
what's the best [ __ ] five years your
seven years you've been working what's
your best year and worst year on income
um that's just a little over 200.
um when i started out maybe
60. okay what do you do but i got
married in there too so
that that adds a lot to it sure sure
what do you do for a living
i do i.t work i.t good for you okay
well there we go and this is theme right
here and uh how much of this money did
you inherit
none of it dave other than i mean i got
a car when i
turned 16 at the average price and
the rest i've kind of worked on i've
done on my own okay
so did you get a four-year degree or you
work in certs
uh no i'd get a 40 i did get a four-year
degree from university yep
nit your science yeah computer science
no computer science yeah okay and what
was yours your gpa
uh about 3.9 good for you okay
all right so tell me the story because
this is you did a large amount in a
short period of time it looks like every
dollar you made went into paid for real
estate
yeah um i've always liked real estate um
i was really fortunate i work
all through even middle school i worked
all the summers
high school i worked after work after
school
i worked full time how old were you when
you bought your first piece of paid for
real estate
um i bought i paid 50 down on my first
house when i was
21. wow way to go brian
man what a great story hey thank you for
sharing that
it's an everyday millionaire theme hour
here on the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you do not believe
that you can become a millionaire
that you can build wealth in america
today
there is a 1 000 chance that you will
not build wealth
because you will not go do the things
that will cause you to build wealth
because you don't think they're going to
work you think the
game is rigged that you don't have a
chance to win
and you do have a chance to win so it is
my job to help you with your belief
and the way i do that is i use facts
not mythology not political
jargon not made up
things but detailed in-depth research
and
talking to real people who have become
wealthy during their lifetime one
definition of wealth is your net worth
it is the most used definition of wealth
to be a millionaire
what you own minus what you owe
so if you have at least a million dollar
net worth
and you're in that situation call me i
want to tell people what everyday
millionaires
really look like not what the media says
not what the left wing nuts say because
oh there are systemic problems with our
economy and the little men
can't get ahead you can't get ahead if
you're a woman you can't get ahead of
your
minority you can't get ahead if you're a
bald boomer
which would be me you can't get ahead
i'm so stupid guys i had to do it twice
i was a millionaire by the time i was 28
and i lost everything because i was
stupid
i borrowed up to my eyeballs i got rich
quick i built a house of cards and it
caved in
and i had to go do it again the second
time i did it i did it using the
principles i've taught you for the last
30 years
since going broke so i've done it twice
you can become a millionaire you can
build
wealth in america but see a farmer that
believes that if he plants
seeds that no crop will grow would never
plant seeds
that would be weird you have there
requires a level of faith the level of
belief that if i plant something i'm
going to grow
something if i save and
sacrifice and stay out of debt and
actually be a grown-up
adults devise a plan and follow a
children do what feels good
then i can become a millionaire if you
do not believe that because
the systemic problems in the economy the
the deck is stacked and people say stuff
like i mean i grew up i heard people
saying
the little man can't get a head
little man can't get ahead
you just work for the man
like eeyore is your freaking spirit
animal
you're never gonna get ahead life's
rough
life's a life's a beach and then you die
you know oh my god you defeat us
fatalistic
idiot but i tell you what man you don't
have to be that way
you can choose to plant corn and voila
corn will grow if you save money
you will have some if you stay out of
debt and live on less than you make
you will eventually build wealth even if
you screw it up
you'll eventually get there kevin is our
next millionaire he's in mobile alabama
kevin what is your net worth
sir we just crossed the threshold
1 million and 42 thousand dollars love
it
good for you give me a little breakdown
on that by category how much real estate
how much
retirement so forth all right we have
right at
this is probably a low ball number 300
000
is our home and it's paid for uh 680
000 and our investments 401k our rate
roth
rra and so forth and then 62 000
in our emergency fund money market you
know cash and other savings how old are
you
60 i just turned 63. good for you and
how much of this did you inherit
zero okay and what has been your working
income
your best year range and your worst year
uh well last year was mostly my income
my wife retired in january of last year
my income last year was right at 80.
probably 86 000. what did she make when
she was working
she probably making 60 plus okay she had
150 000
household income as a high point yeah
yes sir
what was your low point household income
uh probably you know i'm i'm guessing
uh you know 40. yeah okay
and what was your career well i'm
still working uh i'm i'm i work in
production inventory control logistics
warehouse management
basically logistics and warehouse
management gotcha and do you have a
four-year degree
no sir i do not two-year okay in what
uh industrial management yeah and then
you used it good
okay and what was your gpa in that two
year
uh well well i was up there i was i did
it real late in life i graduated when i
was 50. so
after all my squad chances i probably
was right at 3.9 4.0
yeah good for you yeah because you
actually understood what you're supposed
to do yeah
yes sir yes sir good for you good for
you
so what do you tell a young man with a
high school education who's working in
logistics who can go get his two-year
associates
later and he's running his career can he
still be a millionaire
yes sir um you know
my story is kind of like yours i messed
up in
my 39 years old i lost everything long
story won't go there but so i had
the second half of my life i've done a
lot better bear bryant is quoted as
saying there's a lot of
blood sweat and guts between dreams and
success
another quote he says is don't give up
at halftime concentrate on winning the
second half and that's what i've done
second half of my life we buckled down
and concentrated and here we are
i've learned that heroes are not
somebody you see on a movie screen
wearing capes
heroes sometimes wear hard hats and
steel-toed boots i've got a hard hat
sitting next to me i got my steel toe
boots on and
here we are yeah oh there's a whole
bunch of heroes that dress
like that i can tell you yeah they're
not only heroes in the financial world
they're heroes in a spiritual world and
in the leadership world and everything
else real men and women that are getting
crap done out there and
not sitting on some cable news network
whining yeah yes sir
so good for you man good for you i'm
proud of you well done
well done thank you sir i appreciate you
calling and sharing your story and
congratulations on that break in that
plane baby you did it
touchdown yeah
jessica is with us jessica is in
sacramento
hi jessica what's your net worth hi dave
our net worth is 1.2 million good for
you and give me a little breakdown by
category how much real estate and
retirement and so forth
so real estate you know we are in
california our house has paid off and
it's worth
just over 600 000 good
and then we have about 600 000 in roth
ira
mutual funds 401ks etc gotcha
and then about 50 000 cash good for you
well done how old are you i am 39
and my husband is 41. good for you young
millionaires good
how much of this 1.2 did you inherit
well we were fortunate we had
grandparents and great grandparents who
left us
a little bit of money so about 70 000 of
that was from them
uh 50 000 though when i was 18 so
there wasn't much left after very long
okay
so are you a millionaire because of this
inheritance or
it gave you a boost it gave us a boost
okay but you you obviously didn't
inherit a million dollars okay
and your income range what was your best
in your household income
and your worst year household income
since you've been working
our worst year was when we both got off
of active duty
and it was about 15 000 and our best
year
was this last year about 243 000.
cool what do you do for a living i am a
registered nurse
and an air force reservist okay cool and
obviously you have a nursing degree what
was your gpa
from that degree was 4.0 4.0 you got it
get after it i love it
okay so a young nurse is out there
you're a young nurse but even younger
just coming out of school passing her
boards can she still become a
millionaire
absolutely what do you tell her to do
quick
uh choose your life partner wisely and
always move at the state of town
you get like the plague love it move
with the speed of cash and avoid debt
like the plague
you're listening to real millionaires
who have built
real wealth this is not theory these are
real people that are doing it
you can too this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 13 11
dishonest money dwindles away
but whoever gathers money little by
little makes it grow
oh stephen king said what separates the
talented individual from the successful
one
is a lot of hard work well that's true
when people are hurting we want to make
it as easy as possible for them to get
the guidance and the resources they need
to get better
and that's why we do this every day we
help people
over the past year my team has been
really working hard building a brand new
website
that makes it so much easier for you to
find all the different things you need
the content the tools the products the
services
you need to win in any aspect of your
life not just money but everything
and guess what it launches this week
it's called ramseysolutions.com no
kidding
so instead of daveramsey.com we are now
ramseysolutions.com
it's slick it's your one stop shop for
everything ramsay you'll find all our
ramsey personalities there
including rachel ken anthony christie dr
john and of course me
all in one spot and all the things
having to do with us with no wild goose
chase
so just go to ramseysolutions.com check
it out surf around a little bit
see what's happening at the new site
it's beautiful and it's easy to find
stuff
uh the other one had been built like a
country house we just kept adding rooms
over the years and
the architecture was just a wee bit
unstable to say the least
so we're so excited about how strong and
powerful and easy this new one is
just for you guys so well done this
is a millionaire theme hour as we talk
to real millionaires people with a
million dollar net worth or
greater to get from them how they've
lived
how they did that to convince you that
you too
can do this ryan is in indianapolis ryan
what is your net worth
uh 1.1 1.1 million give me a little
breakdown on that
uh mix between everything 200
farmland uh 350 retirement 450
uh equity in the house 100 000 in
investments and
restless miscellaneous cars toys good
for you how old are you
35 and my wife's 41. wow young
millionaires today lots of them
uh how much of this did you inherit
zero okay and what was your best
household income
working year and your worst household
income working year um
zero and uh we're about 200 now cool
what do y'all do for a living
uh i expedite freight my wife works
she's an orthopedic surgical manager
okay all right cool and you have a
four-year degree
no no no degree uh my wife has a
bachelor's
so you got a high school and she's got a
bachelor's correct
okay cool cool so how do you become a
millionaire
at 35 what's the secret um
uh there is no secret you just gotta
work hard and uh save um
i i think that as long as you're having
fun
working on sacrificing and pretending
like it's 1800s
you don't ever need borrow money and uh
just let it live below your means
um before we had kids there was spence
where i'd work
16 to 20 hour days and we were living in
a rented trailer
and we did that to build a solid
foundation and
to save uh to build our house okay
and and you've got a paid for farm and a
house with a bunch of equity in it
a bunch of money in retirement all at 35
years old
yes sir yeah way to go man that house we
just saw a picture of it pop up on
youtube it's beautiful
that's a good looking house man well
done i love it congratulations i'm proud
of you guys
okay so today all of the net worths were
slightly over a million
point three one point four one point one
one one point two one point one
there are no ten million dollars calling
it today no five million or even two
million calling it today
but the ages were unusually young today
37
27 41 35
and 64 and 63. by the way the
statistical average
of a millionaire in america today is 52.
on average it took them 17 years to get
there from the time they got their crap
together and started working on it
okay because we all a lot of people go
through the you know the blue period
where they just do stupid stuff like i
lost everything in my 20s and start over
right
uh and so then 17 years later quicker
than 17 i
had my next million back they always say
the second millions easier
you know it is you know why it is
because you've done it and you know you
can do it when you've never done it
before you don't know
you can do it you think you can do it
you see other people do it you think
this is going to work you can do the
math you can do the projections
but once you've lived in it and done it
you felt it you walked in it you go oh
yeah i can do that
and then you go i need you know i think
i need to work on 10 million and then i
need to work on 30 million and then you
need to you know you just
once you've done it you know you what's
the next
thing you're gonna do what's the next
process
and so these guys did it
and by the way out of them one of them
inherited 200 one of them inherited 70.
both of them said those were booster
seats they were not the reason they
became a millionaire but it did help
and obviously if you get 100 or 200 000
or something like that it does help you
become a millionaire but let me tell you
what the mythology is
if you do take a mic and go down the
street the man on the street interviews
right you say
tell me about wealthy people well they
inherited their wealth
and see if you believe that and you
don't have a rich uncle that means
you're screwed
so why when why go out there and save
why go out there and try to be
successful because the only way to be
wealthy is inherit your money
the game is rigged and if you don't
happen to win the dna lottery
in a wealthy family you're not going to
get there that's that's the problem with
that mythology
is it destroys hope
and the bible says hope deferred makes
the heart sick
here's another one wealthy people are
all crooks that's how they got their
money
well i didn't talk to any crooks today i
talked to a construction manager a
couple i.t guys a logistics guy
a nurse and a and
a and a guy who's a freight distributor
i didn't talk to any crooks
there were no no no movies going to be
made about these people stealing
them bernie madoff was not on the show
today
so this idea that wealthy people are all
crooks is insulting to those of us
that saved and worked our butts off
and didn't steal a dime and provided
service to the marketplace
pisses us off when you say that quit
saying it it's wrong
it's a lie well all wealthy people are
famous people
they're entertainers they're rock stars
country music stars
they play professional sports
the statistically less than one percent
of america's millionaires
are recognizable names due to
them being in the spotlight they're not
professional athletes
statistically less than one percent are
actors
entertainers professional athletes
and i've worked with the nfl we've
worked with the nhl
we've even worked with the nba a couple
of times
and let me tell you what nfl stands for
not for long
their average career length is 3.7 years
the number of guys that become
millionaires playing football
is very low and a lot of them as we all
know screw that up
oh in order to be a millionaire and be
wealthy you have to be inordinately
brilliant another lie
gpas today were all in the threes except
one 4.0
no one had six phds no one had them all
with 4.0
no one invented a a a
a chemistry formula that's going to get
them the nobel peace prize
these are working people that lived on
less than they make
doing i.t nursing
logistics and construction management
now let me just tell you too i will tell
you that the average millionaire
is above a 2.5 gpa
because they applied themselves to their
studies they had a level of discipline
by the way if you go to class most of
the time you get a 2.5
if you just go to class i mean really
and quit playing beer pong i mean just
go to class and you'll get a 2.5
but most of us that are wealthy are not
4.2s
my gpa was 2.97 in college
yes i'm pissed off about the three one
hundredths of a point i missed it by
three one hundredths of a point
so but you know what hadn't held me back
at all i've done okay
the point of this everyday millionaire
theme hour is you can do it
and you should do it and i fully expect
you to do it and i want to hear from you
on this hour
when you do it i want to celebrate you
you're america's heroes
that puts this hour of the dave ramsey
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you